I think it might have thyroid problems, what's the best test for that?
Well, for thyroid issues, you, that's a standard lab test and you want to test for, um,
do a thyroid panel, though, like, um, just going off the top of my head, I got to type
some of those things in that you would test for.
Typically, if you go into your doctor, you say, I want to have my thyroid test and they'll
test for TSH, which is thyroid stimulating hormone. Well, thyroid stimulating hormone is actually
produced by the pituitary gland, and it's basically telling the thyroid to release more formal.
So if the thyroid stimulating hormone is elevated, that's a hint that you might have low thyroid.
But that is so inconclusive. You don't just test TSH and then say you have thyroid
hypothyroid issue. You have to test for the thyroid hormone. So what are the thyroid hormones?
So you got T3. T3 is the active thyroid hormone, but it's really only, um, about 6% of what the
thyroid gland produces. The thyroid gland really produces 94% T4. So T4 is not
an active hormone state. It doesn't have any physical activity to any of the cells. T4 then
converts to T3 in the liver and in the gut at a timely fashion. So when your body needs it over
the course of the day, T4 will convert to T3. Well, problem is then you want to know how much
free T3 and free T4 is. So you would also test for free T3 and you'd also test for free T4.
And then you'd also test for a thing that's called reverse T3, because if you have a sick
gut, then your T4 instead of converting to T3, it converts to this other compound that is
inactive and can never become active. And that's called reverse T3. So you'll want to test for
the percentage of reverse T3 you have, because you might have adequate T4, adequate T3, but you have
very elevated T, reverse T3, and that's the side of thyroid issues, but gut issues and possibly
liver issues. And then you also want to test for TPO antibodies, because that will tell you if you
possibly have Hashimoto's. So that is a more complete thyroid panel. You really want to get,
you know, when we order thyroid panels for people, we order them through lab core, and then we also
get, you know, a CBC ad complete metabolic panel with that too, because we want to look at how the
liver is doing, how the rest of the body is doing, how your blood is doing, that's your complete blood
count, and your complete metabolic panel. That's a more appropriate thyroid function test.